last week more is spike
in cables small bless him for that
five offender oh my god what have I was
problem temporary valve box california
shamballa so and and to you so
karmi's this week for are taken the
less did given by the this
morning i like  it can go back to the
one in 15 languages and couples porridge to eat p
rridge henny lee fight auto and me already on the d
pper programs that were there is legis
ator is the core hits in oregon from
y 10 million in my week to naval
port milli
n  this way half kilo nigella a
prominent in ringlet
there is something carolina people that
people are people saying
therefore minute party people about en de
isolate choice
economic hardship is something that by
definition
you do not right people about young people
toucher close2you en l&m struggling know
it's christmas  is coming out in for the
daze every
and so you with this is a family am
hoping that would eat when i wanna
brings and you were successful and
depl  oyment you live show business je now
we are here program a tripod a
you well there is a program to help you
jump start your eyes were life can start
a new business at handicare fast people
can come to you
omg so anonymous combination of pipe
starks en the s&p 500 this out in
silicon valley and big-box retailers yes
there is still so far your and I have to go in and
pushed entrepreneurship and this country
this is that
small businesses shows the day people who
poverty politicians in dc you de polder
the breath
yes cm bigger the banana and and inputs and
program cell third three skill the
workforce okay vine like the reed growers
a vault in a breach in mud rub my
dad and your skil doin your data
spin the lime zest and trillions of dollars
show you the new green part true  i stand
tables and the eel bridges and work and
infrastructure nationwide and by the way
the powerplus thousand euros longa
virtualizer just be ready to wear
tomorrow
mim
sr policy should be smart and help people
you wanna  start businesses and have good
work at six people defined opportunities
in stars panky pop baby isolated and
see it in their homes and collect and a
planet
sorry is what they had to do essential
use existing
exactly what clean cancer are there
another i think an emoji
trillion dollar chemical signals
that inhibit stimulus johanna van der ark ten
million americans
of 13 million plushpool of americans
clicking a prominent red de haven
of your course there there there
contract workers her self employed
the people who don't qualify for stitch and
a 3  manager at loyens wil hey indians
prominent shirt van zoneren qualified
for double engine freshest and worn out
perfect
xtandit jumps benefited is baked john
gift for his new comic watched km10
you already know where experts on december of
your text so those oil digitizers
the department this is bill  is doing is
discorder.com extend a disco in the
xtender en selection moratorium
casu who call m in bring there is  a live
the people were busy benedict er per
single single working mothers and less
in it
juliet and family fallback want to take
a new and dress it and there from the
basics or to the bower stimulus
check in there is some swift a
birthday card british  na could do
address only the fundamental and delicious
and nothing shard and this is what you see
is a pain that had always wanted
to do the drive like this one
boot sites also to the the wider than the
fact that we can get these guys  its
place to go on gender check using this
app and the goal [ __ ] to her i get people
to how how to make this money january
that's neat the handout be given to
people if they haven't got a reality
check epik high unemployment is going  up
famous brands
zo is people arduini angry disclose the
action and people and conquer sweet ben
finding and buying this whole time in the
store
jobs
then something to lead the room in this
is so de Stof oh this is the design de
dat upris  ing de you talking about it is
all other people the after was in comes in
by any other condition hatching
out lola jo
lak george is a poll said george
there from all actions on generative
en knowledge edessa laddermolen porno
presidential election of you enjoy this
letter  short circuit of the podcast that
we this here is another shirt site me
to all of you wanna see the entire
podcast click on library java bali
past
[Music]